whoa okay the map is not here no it's
it's it's there it's just always there
it's taken on a different form that's
all alright what's up guys welcome back
to potato mode the show we take the most
beautiful games we know and we just make
the graphics look pretty terrible
my name is Joey I'm joined by Nick
margarita here howdy and we as you can
see are finally getting around to
fortnight I know a lot of you have been
saying in the comments for ivers
basically ever since the show started
but we're gonna do it here we're gonna
try to make it look as nasty as possible
but right now we got a lot looks
beautiful right Nick's plane right now
and the game does look pretty good
all the the fortnight comments saying
that oh this looks better than fortnight
at least I mean come on
fortnight is a pretty decently looking
game it's a gorgeous game it really is
like a props to epic its it's only the
fact that you can actually play it on
any computer yes that's what makes it a
little kind of you know low quality out
like with lower specs but here we have
the game running on like 1080p like all
Ultra settings it looks beautiful
alright let's go ahead and let's get
spicy let's go get spicy so let's go to
retail retail road because we know
people will be there oh I think I see a
chest over there oh no there's a one
would they see me oh oh he's oh he had a
really good skin oh it's the cool skin
alright we'll go somewhere spicy this
time does that start that star okay so I
guess here well we'll do every death
will reduce it again further so I'll
take the reins first alright time to
reduce now let's go low right we got
everything on low we also have the
resolution scaling at 44% are you gonna
drop it all the way oh my gosh oh my god
all the menu items look so good though
didn't we go oh my god
close to the mobile version right now
still though I can see what things are
like I can still move around the bus
still resembles the bus it just looks
like this is like a really old version
of the yeah we're playing on the Gameboy
Advance
oh we're gonna go tilted oh yeah we're
gonna get nice and spicy because after
this death it's all downhill again not
that bad it seems to be mostly like
resolution right here like the jagged
edges which is you know fine but that
doesn't really make a difference right
as long as you can aim I think that's
the important part gotcha yeah nice one
all right
we're cooking with gas now it's it's not
bad but I'm like oh boy yeah you guys it
makes you second-guess like certain
things like wait did I see that big move
or was that just the screen tearing oh
crap oh I don't even know there is there
is room I was like where is he see those
two pixels in distance like it's back
back alright are we going down again
yeah let's go down again so we're good
we're gonna leave this game well we're
gonna go even further this time because
we've run out of options to turn down
we're just gonna go with the gold in
video profile inspector if you remember
that from yeah the see if these
absolutely yeah with me so we're doing
the level of detail bias which by the
way and the finally after doing the show
for several months figured out what it
actually does Twitter user actually of
message me and and we were discussing it
and they basically said that it makes
items that are close to you they make as
if the texture is rendered further away
oh if you turn it all the way up that
means something is right in front of you
is using a texture that was meant to be
used like 50 yards away oh I understand
okay that is a character so maybe it
does that was a character there's
supposed to be I think two characters in
that spot it looks like a claymation go
to the other skins that you have let's
look through them a little bit the color
of the game is gone for this one the
helmets so good oh how about this one
cuz there was a light show
oh is cuz he's supposed to be like
really bright is it a little outfits
like all lights or whatever not anymore
that one just looks like doodoo ironies
the doo doo one yeah
oh it's pretty cool all right we're
dabbing alright let's do it
you ready yeah the image is not here
there's no image what what I feel like
we have an advantage I would say we're
in a barren wastes on one hand there's
there's nothing in the way there's no
there's no like foliage or whatever if
on the other hand you're dealing with
some pretty tiny models here if I get a
kill here it's gonna blow my mind all
right battle bus whoa whoa okay the map
is not here no it's it's it's there it's
just oh it's taken on a different form
that's all
nevermind what we were saying about the
map looking fine yeah let's try to go -
I don't know salty can you see the mark
are you still see the marker you can
still see the marker all right so I know
in general where I want to go we should
jump soon my eyes are starting to hurt
all right let's get out of here I think
we're close to the ground I'm not sure
another guy just like oh that was a
cloud oh so I can see the items pretty
easily all right let's see going up
going up where was that we have a weapon
oh gosh okay night-night well seeing as
how we can't really make it lower this
will just we'll just go into the ramp
we'll go another round another round all
right let's go we'll go to the divot
dusty divot will go to the the big hole
all right so these are all clouds right
I think so I want to say that the clouds
are some sort of like particle effects
or I guess the chug chug is actually not
appearing in our inventory but it's
there just believe us
oh sheesh who is that where was that I
don't know is this a hill can I go over
this yeah I can go I would say oh you
should all I hit him in the head
I just get the hell out of it cuz I
don't know if that other guy died or not
we're gonna get him oh I don't know
where he is I don't know where he is
get out of here where's the damage I go
oh oh
scared me we still got a kill we got a
snipe kill to run it back one more time
one more one more
he'll do one more dude I'm actually
fired up about that kill leave out even
get some rewards good Chi Chi tried
tilted yeah let's go back to tilted yeah
cuz there's like a lot of like buildings
to be a lot of people like all over on
the same spot oh it's just the hills are
disappeared the terrain is completely
good terrain it's gone excuse me
oh my god how do I get up to you what do
you think what do you think Drake would
say about this
oh man Drake would love this he is it'd
be his new favorite for I feel like he
would just he would be upset he would
make like a diss track about potato
maloni
there will be I promise you there will
be aged a Drake song Abbas helmet thread
there will be a song about fortnight in
his neck see he's know is the album come
out today so his album is out I just
read about this oh the Drake's new album
is out and he has a track on there
called March 14th and while he didn't
say it specifically people are saying oh
that's the day that he streamed
fortnight ninja yeah I noticed you
haven't been doing a lot of uh
destruction or just like gathering I can
do that and maybe just bring down a
couple walls I want to see oh god some
of that done on potatoes oh it's just
like it disappears it just goes away
save on memory resources this way right
we're gonna drink that we're gonna full
potion we're ready ready to rock and
roll and assault riff you know what the
funny thing is I can't tell what level
any of these guns are because they're
not there what they're not purple well
you can you can see like the the color
when you pick them up yeah but like when
they're on the ground they're just what
was that a person yeah that's definitely
a dude it looks like a gray blob Oh
Oh how was this guy not dead oh my gosh
I'm so bad
God ah there we go ah thank God
let's just blame it on the graphics yeah
I can't really see no but that really
that's alright well think about what
what he's feeling here he has no idea
that we're playing like this if he knew
he would feel very I would love it if
they showed a replay and shows it he's
like jacked up our computer yeah it
shows like our side we're back oh I see
someone running here I actually feel
like it's easier see people who are far
away yeah I think it's just like less
distractions but still how do you even
see that
Oh someone's building yeah saw someone
go ugly near be careful there they gotta
be like right here hi Oh Oh thought I
hit him first did we get him we hit him
ah we hit him we were close well I think
that's about it oh my goodness that does
it for this episode of potato mode if
you guys have a game that you'd like to
see potato fide much like this and what
yeah if you guys have a game just make
sure leaving in the comments or his up
on Twitter oh yeah let's go see let's go
through some of the dances alright these
aren't bad they still operate they still
work and then my my personal favorite of
course what a way to go out
alright well thank you Nick for joining
me on dad my way out of this video yeah
and we will see you guys next Friday
sorry telling all the epileptics out
there I had no idea this was gonna
happen
once we land I think we'll be fine let's
look up at the sky okay that's that's a
little bit better yeah all right don't
look at that uh